6 37 on tuesday morning kids on summer
break
and here at 8 news now we're trying to
help you and your family find ways to
do some fun stuff all week long it's our
summer fun series today
how about a camp for kids looking to
hone their acting
skills bianca holman is live to tell us
more about it hey bianca
hey good morning nate so we've talked
about dancing we've talked about
performing arts even regular camp
that's starting today june 1st here in
the city of las vegas but again if your
child is ready to take center stage
ready for their debut we have a
performing arts camp for them and to
share more uh um you know what that you
also shared that
about the rainbow uh company but also
tell us
about another camp that is available for
families
well we have an incredible opportunity
with the office of cultural affairs to
run
many camps throughout our seasons and in
this year at the west las vegas arts
center they are in their 25th year
of the performing and visual arts camp
and that is offered for ages 10 to 15
and that focuses our an arts curriculum
on theater
and dance and music and video production
as well as photography so it's an
amazing opportunity for students to
really dig in
into some intense training and that will
culminate in a performance at the end of
the two weeks
wow thank you so much jessica and also
about the um
details does is there a cost associated
when does it start do they perform at
the end
there is a cost associated with that
it's 400 for the two weeks it runs
july 7th through the 17th all the
information is at our website
artslasvegas.org and there they can find
an application they have to go through
an application process for that
and we still have seats left and
we're ready to go and ready for more
more students to jump in
incredible and i know as an educator in
the performing arts
you know just how important this is and
the difference that it's going to make
in kids life tell us
your thoughts on that you know i just
feel like this is an incredible
opportunity for
us to reach out into the community in so
many ways and offer healing to all of
our youth and
and really give opportunities um that
they haven't had obviously in the last
year and so we're grateful for that
we're building relationships with parks
and rec
to be able to continue to bring
opportunity to these camps
and specialize we're teaching we're
sending teaching artists out to just
really give as much as we possibly can
to the community right now as we all
heal
our kids needed parents needed we need
to get our kids back
out there socializing so again great
opportunities offered here in the city
of las vegas
we've got two different performing arts
camps and do performances at the end
dance intensive dance with
professionally trained uh teachers from
alvin ailey and across the country
and then also you got your regular day
camp where again they're doing sports
they're doing a little bit of acting in
there
they're going to the pool so something
for everybody to get plugged into this
right now and get all this information
on our website eightnewsnow.com going to
send it back to you guys in the studio